it was great seeing pilar back at the
ballpark tonight took the lineup cards
out
and uh got a nice ovation from the fans
here in atlanta as well and tucker
davidson jeff makes his first big league
start for the braves tonight
yeah lefty you see ranked the braves
eighth best prospect 25 years old
2-0 with .64 and two starts in gwinnett
he's going to fastball mid 90s good
curve good slider
as davidson fields his position well
throws a low
throw to fray the sinker and the braves
gold glove first baseman
saves the throwing error yeah freddy
should admire that one that was a long
hop and a heck of a play
two outs he's the only one drafted from
that school to make the big leagues
check swing the appeal he went strike
three good slider
and a one two three top of the first
inning for tucker davidson
let's see if miguel castro can keep him
down for the first inning or two and
that's always have trouble
keeping those uh trio or quartet of
hitters down
that badly toyota numbers for castro
who's been outstanding this is his
second
opener start also started two times when
he was in a baltimore oriole uniform
and the slider in for a call third
strike and acuna knew it
and castro's got a strikeout to start
his night
hunters over four in a bigly career
first pitch tommy hunter swings and
lines a base hit to left
now that's how you do it get up there
and hack away tommy hunter
looks like dion sanders going up the
first baseline
and i think this must be his first major
league hit because he's calling for the
baseball
he's been around forever is this really
his first major league hit
he was only 0 for four coming into this
season give me the ball
i want the ball 34 years old and he
finally gets his first big league hit
and you bet you he's going to save the
ball jonathan fiore grounded out to
short his first time up
i'd love to see hunter speed around the
bases on a ball in the gap
that's driven in the air to left center
field pretty deep echoes ozuna looks up
and it's out of here jonathan vr with a
two-run homer
third home run of the season hunter gets
to score a run
and vr with his third home run gives the
mets a two-nothing lead
third home run first as a right-hand
batter
and hunter does get to circle the bases
well fastball right down the middle vr
knew as soon as he made contact it was
gone the back foot
was in the air when he made contact with
that home run
and the mets bench and hunter and
everyone for whatever reason
are just so
i don't know they're inspired or what
he's done
lindor the start he got off to i mean
look that's
sometimes equals somebody's job
unfortunately
0-2 pitch strike three paints a corner
at 95 on the black and alonso
couldn't believe that so four strikeouts
for tucker davidson pitching a good ball
game he's made one mistake and it's cost
him two runs that's a great pitch
oh one pitch shot out to short backhand
stop deep in the hole by dansby pops up
and a bullet over to first base
beautiful play by dansby swanson to rob
tomas nedo
i'm not sure ben but i think he was
already going into that
pop-up slide before he ever caught the
ball
and a good throw over to freddie so now
runner in scoring position with nobody
out
one and one count to ozuna and another
breaking ball hit up the middle peraza's
got it now they got freeman in a rundown
garaza looking around now gazellman
finally puts on the tag and ozuna got to
second base
so freeman did a good job sting in the
rundown long enough
so that ozuna could get the extra base
and replace him at second
you know every runner knows that the
balls hit to your left you go but in
today's
shift game that is not always the case
but freeman makes up for it here
by making sure c's waving ozuna to make
sure he takes second base and gives
himself up
when he knows the play is dead pitch
swinging a missed strike three good
sinking 95 mile an hour fastball from
gesellman that swanson couldn't catch up
to
and the inning is over no runs no hits
one left we'll go to the bottom of the
fourth mitts or they're going to the
fifth inning now mitch laid two nothing
so vr is the hitting villain for new
york
a two-run homer is the only offense in
the game
and this one is popped into shallow
center dan's be on the run
ozzy's there and got undercut and the
catch is made who's got it
is it dan's me is it ozzie i can't i
think ozzy
no who does have it you got two
guys going after the ball and that's not
one of those that you really can call
because you're both running so fast
what a job by dansby to have his eye on
it you see ozzy at the last second
i think they look they both would have
caught it so casselman had to run the
bases for a while let's see if that
affects him against austin reilly who
bounced out in his loan trip
swinging a shot hammered toward right
center field that ball
is gone line drive home run for austin
riley
jeff he's starting to figure it out we
were wondering if that power surge was
gonna come
he got comfortable and now you're seeing
him take aggressive
confidence swings and not only that
right center field
that ball was hit on it line the wind
did nothing to that ball
that ball's out no matter what and you
can tell it's a kid that's getting
confident more confident every day well
tucker davidson with a crisis to manage
here first and third nobody out pete
alonso for two
two and two to alonso now the pitch
swing on a fly ball hit to pretty deep
center should score a run a radio back
makes the catch lyndorn tags at third
he'll come home to score as the throw
goes to second
the braves did clip him last night let's
see if they can do it again they trail
by two again
freddie is grounded out and walked swing
and a fly ball
hammered straight away center that one
is
into chattahoochee falls oh
what is it bad for freddie freeman
another atlanta missile
and they get that run back that might
have been the hardest ball phrase hit
all year
that was into the second level of
chattahoochee falls
perfect field goal between those two
evergreen trees
so it's a 3-2 game now riley has homered
each of the last two nights and now
freeman
those are all the runs the braves have
scored in this series
and albie's lofts one out to right
center over in the gap goes lee
diving and he made the catch khalil lee
welcome to the new york mets a brilliant
diving catch by khalil leader rob ozzy
albee's at extra bases
well you can't teach speed and khalil
lee has that
a lot of options for loop here with an
even count
and it's stroked into the left center
field of base hit he got a cutter
adrianza around first he's thinking
about two the fargus throw
is going to be not in time he got in
oh i was waiting for jim wolfe to ring
him up
but adrianza got in ahead of the throw
and he called him safe
1-1 rounds one on the right side grabbed
by lindor he makes the tag
makes the toss double play
francisco lindor playing in the shift
there was no way he could throw the ball
to second there was nobody there
so he had to go for the tag on acuna got
him
and threw out freeman from the double
play oh zuna the final hope of the
inning
first and second nobody out now runner
at third two outs
and down a run familiar ready the pitch
broke it bad and ozona comes through to
tie it up
the barrel of the bat ends up behind
home plate
all marcel have was the bad handle
and the braves get a huge pick-me-up
game-tying run
we're 3-3 and then after the hit he
tossed what he had left in the air
1-1 count
gets absolutely blown up
so two out of nobody on now tomos nido
and nito snacks one in the air to deep
left center back goes ozuna onto the
warning track at the wall
it's out of here the mets take the lead
in the ninth on a tomas needle home run
neato left in the lineup because he's
hot with the bat and he delivers a
huge home run with two out of the top of
the ninth his second home run of the
season
and the mitz laid at four to three
the irregulars keep producing the first
time this season for edwin diaz pitching
a third straight day
again the 1-2 to swanson and he struck
him out he said i'll work four days in a
row i don't care
swing and a miss he struck him out
and he pops one up into center field
fargus is there and the ball game is
over
diaz pitching a third straight day
throws a one two three ninth
tomas nido with the go ahead home run in
the top of the inning and the mets with
back-to-back
unlikely wins